so now that wano is over the new one
piece op has finally dropped but there
is one small detail I wish more people
were given credit to like the whole
thing is obviously amazing instant top
five one piece openings no doubt the
visual Direction and production alone is
insane and secures that for me but it's
this upcoming bit here I really enjoyed
I've seen a lot of people praising this
part for how many outfits Luffy goes
through but no one is talking about the
cut right afterwards where everyone in
the crew is changing outfits based on
the floor they're stepping on matching
that Arc it's such a lively and well
unnecessary detail but it really
broadens that sense of time that the
Luffy outfits were going for and is no
doubt one of hundreds of wonderfully
thoughtful hidden details throughout
this opening what were some of your
favorites did you notice anything that I
missed